on va se regarder cette petite arena
francophones vont être spectateur du
truc mais le pouce bleu parce que j'ai
envie et on va profiter de la première
partie alors on va s'enlever les
évaluations des machins et truc on va
juste garder les coûts en haut à droite
et on va se regarder cette partie entre
française man alors française man c-46
annoncé qu'un des quatre des cinq cordes
des cap des 5 c 4 600 cas pas plus jouer
la france a gelé où il fait quand même
un des 5 e 6 quand il s'en fout quoi que
tu fasses il te fait une française
cavalière froissé 6 donc slave triangle
et il allait prendre le pion en c4 parce
que c'est rentrer dans une capitale and
food les deux cavaliers
si ces cavaliers e5 donc les blancs
veulent récupérer une pure leucate et
par la suite quand ces quatre pardon il
par la suite joué avec eux quatre pour
prendre le contrôle du centre et on
imagine que les noirs vont vouloir jouer
alors soit avec des 5 fu bessat tc5
rapide soit avec b 5 pour tenir le pion
mais ça paraît du riz siècle le quart
alliances & cie s'élève à fait fou b4 et
chaque hors jeu pas spécial cette
variante a pris 6 et 3 me paraît logique
ouf ou des deux fous d'être fou des deux
j'avais peur de me prendre des quatre
faut prendre b4 dame prend 2,5 mais
peut-être qu'il veut jouer alors ça
c'est intéressant que jeter un oeil il
veut peut-être joué sur le fou de cases
noires qui contrôlent ces cases la met
près peut-être ça existe et que je
connais pas donc je veux pas remettre en
cause mais il ya quand même deux pions
il ya la menace ces cinq cavaliers ses
six essais sur tarn prendre un café ou
autre chose et que je rate un mais
qu'est ce que je peux rater écoutez
c'est la partie mais ouais alors il ya
une variante comme ça dans la slave je
pourrais éventuellement vous montrez
allez je vous montre je fais une petite
digression a decade des 5 c 4 6
cavaliers c3 c6 eu quatre pions prend
cavaliers prend donc ses astra triangle
foulée quatre échecs fou des deux dames
prend des quatre fous prend dame prend
peu quatre échecs foule deux et je sais
plus si on fait dame jusqu'à va me
ranger de jouer ça mais je me rappelle
plus on joue jusqu'à dame pranger de
mais en gros l'idée c'est que les blancs
ils ont un pion - mais ils ont le fou
qui contrôle on va essayer juin un truc
avec cavaliers à 6 avec les noirs ou
cavaliers 17 essais 5 pour chasser le
fouet des fonds joue avec
petit rock des fois avec son rock ça
dépend en gros cette idée existe sauf
que là c'est une idée qui est un peu
plus cher parce qu'il ya deux pions
moins pour les blancs et en plus les
noirs sont quand même très proche de
jouer c'est simple parce que la dame est
pas hors jeu donc ça sent un semis
danger alors tous ces trois dames c'est
ça qui est un roc a et b 17 hockey donc
oui la ya juste deux pions plus et c'est
une excellente position pour les noirs
alors à trois c'est une idée pas mal
c'est que sur roc qui veut faire
fouiller 4 vous prend et fuite c'est
dommage sur a3 il aurait pu jouer
éventuellement à 5 contrôler la casse b4
et éviter le piège et prendre de
l'espace
et c'est parce qu'il a fait donc il perd
une qualité française man c'est dommage
pour française man parce que française
man mais il avait ses pions de plus il a
sa petite position sympathique et il
fait il fait il à faire un vrai cadeau
la française man c'est ce dommage quoi
donc il revient en bessin qu'avec la
dame d'accord il protège le pion il va
falloir essayer de jouer avec eux cinq
faut aussi se garder de pure envie mais
je pense pas qu'ils puissent banon il
peut pas en fait je suis bête les façons
même s'ils réussissent à faire tout et
si ce machin n'y arrive pas donc il n'y
a plus qu'un pion pour la qualité et à
cette colonne des ouverte mais c'est pas
encore si simple à gagner il faut pas
faut pas abandonner alors là ouais là
encore dommage t&d de leur tour il y
avait d'apprendre d'eux peut-être tour
d'amd 5 je sais pas si ça a marché mais
fallait il fallait jeter un oeil au nez
blanc qui va les changer là je pense
qu'il n'a pas trop le choix
cependant il a le choix non c'est pas
mal joué je sais pas ben on s'était en
fait j'ai été tenté par quoi j'étais
tentée par prise m'ont surprise de la
d'alger tête ont fait tour d2 et on
embrouilles et surtout prend je lisais
ce que fout b3 peut être une idée pour
gagner cette colonne et faire cavalier
russie s'est joué sur le fait que l'on
contrôle avec les noirs la seule colonne
ouverte donc que les tours blanches ont
du mal à rentrer en jeu ça pouvait être
une idée stratégiques intéressantes
il s'est fait changer le cavalier là
maintenant il va falloir qu'ils se
battent à fond pour pas laisser rentrer
les blancs parce que les blancs veulent
rentrer sur la colonne s'est vraiment en
force des cas que j'aime pas trop il s
vie aux fous non là c'est il aurait
peut-être pu être elle a maintenant truc
c'est que bombers god il a bien joué on
revient point de s'efforcer quoique bon
je n'ai pas trop des cartons sont sales
et c'est le truc mais cinq d'entre eux
deux c'est un oubli a peut-être tout à
me prendre cinq mois ça va le fait
qu'ils aient d'un projet que j'avais pas
vu ça lui permet d'encore être en vie
mais après j'ai pas trop aimé truc de
joie étaient 4 ou quoi mais fo qui ouais
je pense von bergen qui a oublié le pion
de deux parce que c'est pas assez la
deuxième fois qu'il laisse en prise en
un donc il a dû l'oublier et du coup il
voyait ses shows il a un peu embrouillé
avec un jeu précis les plans doivent
encore être assez bien je crois que
j'avais je crois que j'ai vu une
variante marrante mais je sais pas si ça
marchait je pense à toury 6e de pourpre
en d1 dames tout reprend tout reprend
fois fin flash trois amis avaient
dameuse vous vous bouffer ses gagnants
ou autre chose ailleurs
bomberman qui gruber got paravent
j'appelle bomberman massé bombers god
qui a réussi finalement à stabiliser la
position de l'écurie bien bloqué
maintenant il faut qu'ils essayent de
s'en emparer 600 ans par ce sera facile
or il prend 17 ce qui est pas idiot du
tout mais ça avec les noirs lé noir
réussissent pas à faire une idée ouais
non mais il ya quand même une idée à
lille veut faire tous réussissent donc
et c'est bien joué de la part de l'un
française man qui est quand même
résistants faut souligner c'est dommage
qu'il se soit fait avoir tout à l'heure
ils résistent ils prouvent qu ils
existent fr touré fils la fosse battre
un cavalier e set est pourquoi pas
j'avais envie de le garder là le cavale
je sais pas pour essayer de faire car il
ya eu 5 mai qu'a eu cette il veut tout
ni rien et maintenant fou aux quatre
c'est bien c'est très bien joué de la
part de bons burgers death et ouais il
ya eu des petites scories à gauche à
droite mais c'est pas mal joué
là je crois que il faut échanger un
maître lecavalier 6 allez faut essayer
un jeu comprend pas l'idée sur d'un
premier set
parce que même province est tout aussi
ceux pour embrouiller il ya d'amd dam
des huit hommes font des bonds sont
ralliés na li na qui rentrent les a par
exemple un stream demande est là tout le
monde t'attend s'est bien passé ouais et
donc on ça s'est bien passé aussi bon et
écoute moi je te propose des anacondas y
suivre comme un chiffre qui tend à voir
ludovic alors qu'est ce qui nous fait
ludwig partie 901 9 cents contre 1 500
c'est beau c'est beau le kart 2 5 pouces
et 4 qui avait six détroit ces six caves
trois des cinq plus vie qui prend le
centre rapidos kevin chan du fou contre
les cavaliers par un petit truc belgique
je trouve que tu mets un peu de temps à
développer ton roi alors là ça va aller
1 tu vas t'en sortir mais c'est juste un
peu long tu as même là un bonbon pour un
peu revenu au score et peut-être fou
bekkat rock tu vois essayer de vite
rockets c'est quand même dangereux de
mettre autant de temps nos 12e coûte
étaient encore à deux coups du rock
donc c'est vrai qu'on aurait quand même
cette intuition de bouger le fou un peu
plus rapidement et tu vas au lieu
d'avancer au centre parce que ça peut
coûter des fois tu as il aurait pu le
faire un petit peu je sais pas mais à
tour je sais pas ici son adversaire
n'est pas non plus peut-être ne joue pas
non plus de 2 de manière optimale mais a
il veut jouer grand roque luigi gré mais
grand roque il te manque quand même un
pion ces firmes sont que tu t'embarques
dans des choses qui sont un peu complexe
après c'est une remarque personnelle
j'en sais rien mais je trouve que
l'impression qui s'en va renaître hugues
du ku'damm c4 qu'il ya des fourmis qui
sont arrivés pour manger du miel alors
dames c'est 400 propio f700 préemption à
vii viii qui fasse je sais pas ça manque
d'idées là ce que je comprends rien à ce
qui fut en fait où il y avait foule
prend d2 après après tout mais je
comprends rien à ce qui se passe c'est
frais c'est vrai là je suis un peu
déconcentré je voyais pas fou prend des
deux qui arrivait mais je sais pas ça
manque vraiment d'harmonie côté blanc et
noirs après c'est vrai que c'est des
joueurs qui sont encore pas très bien
classé mais pas essayer de jouer plus
normal alors la côte et côté noir là
d'avoir joué ces six des 5 pourquoi pas
jusque là on peut dire que les deux
joueurs on veut plus ou moins logique là
peut-être un petit coup de tourer ça
faisait pas de mal pour tous et le pion
voir ce qui se passe
fawcett un petit coup comme dame g3
peut-être pour s'en prendre ici est
développé par kaos et 3g pas les pièces
sont pas forcément déjà très bien placé
mais on l'apprêté des tactiques avec
tourcoing quatre cavaliers prendre un
point est fait mais je suis pas sûr que
ça marche
peut-être même fou cette dame point f
cell 3d cette dame d'amis ces dames
points 4 mais jafar là ça manque un peu
de liant un peu tout ce qui se passe
dans cette partie enfin et qui prend le
cadre des cinq week était très bien joué
pour dévier la dame la praille c'était
bien joué ça de la part de belgique
passé 15 9
c'est très chaotique comme parti mais ça
c'était pas mal fait b5 pour chasser la
dame mais dur de suivre des parties de
500 surtout des ambitions qui jouent
mieux que leur classement
ce pas si mal ce qu'ils font juste je
sais pas
on va voir cette finale ce que ça donne
voilà
là on a bien envie de remettre un kenyan
à 4,6 à florence et 7 qui est 17 c'est
peut-être un peu vraiment ça va brasser
sept cavaliers affichent 6 ou cavaliers
ou cinq affaires brassées 7,8 des clous
et placer les tours maintenant cavalier
verser 4 peut-être un jour s'il faut
disparaît au mans tours à huit salles et
dirais qu'il faut découvrir ici c'est
important de des clous et histoire de
regagner la mobilité avec le carré après
on peut aussi faire qu'à lycéens car là
pour des clous et quand même plutôt roi
c'est cette j'ai pas le rend un peu plus
centralisée contrat le plus de cases il
est pas en danger sur cases noires il
est mieux placé sept pour un jour même
monté intervenir on débite il est un peu
hors du jeu sur un comme fouet trois ici
du coup allez les blancs menace le
cavalier alors c'est rien de grave on
fera cavalier e 5 ans restent
complètement gagnant mais laurent c7 est
mieux placé il couvre plus de cases
il est plus proche du centre il est tout
simplement plus fort comme cahier des
cathos si possible ici pour les noirs
mais je viens kg 5 ce que je dis
surveillance et 4,7 est pas mal on va
voir on va voir comment çà çà çà çà çà
se passe et plus des 8 va reprendre de
la tour j'imagine
il peut être roi c'est cette ici quand
même monté droit c'est important le roi
en fait il pourrait éventuellement
colmater les casses d'entrée de la tour
auquel acquis les provinces est donc là
ce qui était pas mal pour lui fixer qui
tenait il tonné les 15 élus de vie qui a
gagné une partie dure à suivre quand
même allez on va on va regarder des
joueurs échec 960 69009 et t'inquiète
pas ça va bien se passer
contrainte vote berry joue cette petite
variante de la sicilienne or c'est un
jour de cech over chez commerce
conséquence les cavaliers f3 ce truc-là
100 kgs c3 mais là il peut avoir une
idée c'est de faire d'amd de b3 foulée 2
c'est une idée qui avait été jouée par
magnus carlsen contre vuelta c'est qu'on
avait d'ailleurs vu une vidéo sur la
chaîne et je pense que c'était plus ou
moins dans cette position mais bon il
fait france et si ces machins qui est
logique les noirs qui joue comme une
flèche nikov avait que cinq classes qui
est très importante pour les noirs c'est
de rapidement essayé de jouer pour
dessein est donc là je pense à un coût
très important pour pour les noirs
pardon du avec des cinq je pense que
c'est important pour les blancs de
réussir à faire flou g5 sepa sct des
bonnes conditions mais là le truc c'est
que si les noirs font rock rock et des
cinq je vois pas pourquoi les noirs
aurait pas un avantage même parce qu'ils
ont la peur de fou majorité centrale
ça semble être quand même
deux points très positifs après avoir
mais ça me semble être vraiment de
points
important ok il a fait des cinq
séquences qui est en train de se passer
voir cavaliers prends ça va échanger
ça va les changer et grands alors
laquelle prend 3 il peut céder 25 là les
noirs sont vraiment mieux peut dire que
les blancs pas super maîtriser
l'ouverture il a voulu jouer un truc un
peu original mais qui maîtrisait pas
trop et la paire de fou qu'on perd deux
cavaliers dans ce genre de position
c'est dur je le demande en fait il n'est
pas fou g5 marché ici surtout reprend
des huit vous prend 2,3 et sur f4 qui on
prend au quai du coup surtout reprendre
et 8 en fait plus on prend 1,3 en
gagnant un pion cavaliers pros f4 forcé
et du coup peut-être damas cinq mais au
moins on a fragilisé les blancs de
partout où dams et c'est d'ailleurs dans
pas mal d'options
et c'est m6 intervient à cinq il en voit
qui est des cinq bien joué de la part
des blancs il se débarrasse d'un des
cavaliers et il veut mettre l'autre sur
des cinq ans même si c'est pas lundi les
arénas arcep en sus parle de l'aréna
bleed stream qui est un lundi sur nous
ou des arénas francophones qui sont les
jeudis
et le loup moss premier
il a réussi ce coquet
comme ça tu as quatre à trois une idée
ensuite alors avec les blancs je pense
qu'en gros ce qu'il faut faire c'est pas
se casser la tête à jouer sur le roi
faut jouer sur la colonne des c'est le
c'est notre seule gloire mais c'est une
belle gloire là on peut faire tour 17
est en fait la tacc des noirs est
peut-être un poil landes par rapport à
notre contrôle il faut vraiment jouer la
colonne des à fond là pour les blancs
dont kg 3 pourquoi pas mais on laisse à
3 je pensais encore le temps de faire
tour 17
en fait j'aime vraiment tour 17 pour
pour les blancs ce qu'on peut s'échanger
les dames quoi du coup
j'aime bien j'aimais bien le faire aux
coups précédents quand même tour 17
parce que du ku'damm c5 je crois - ce
que je bugs et bouffe bouffe tout
retombe et 7 mais j'aime bien ce
cavalier à eux deux il est utile il
protège ses trois vraiment quand vous
avez une colonne ouverte rentrée dessus
un les colonnes sont faites pour être
pénétrée 1
si vous avez une colonne et que vous
vous rentrez pas dedans ça sert à rien
quoi ça fait joli mais c'est pas utile
là et avait un truc jolie d'ailleurs
est-ce que ça marchait je me demande
c'est pas tour des huit échecs vous
prend des huit tours prend des huit
tours prend des huit pas possible donc
croivent cette fin ce qu'on perd la dame
bref cette force et dames bouffe tour
bouffe et tour bouffe je pense qu'il a
raté sa chance sur d8 marché je sais pas
j'ai pas d'ordi donc je peux pas je peux
pas vérifier à quoi que je peux pas lui
mais les lignes mais je crois que tour
des mythes marché et le retour des 8
gagner assez l'entraîneur tactique ça
les amis un c'est pas difficile 1
williams est juste ou reprend fou il
veut faire tour ces deux et venir
essayer de ma tenait encore le mettra
pas retour c4 c'est pas grave ça c'est
dommage je veux pas manger le fou quand
même genre mètres lors d un petit bout
puisque la et des coûts qui me
surprennent quand même et on prend des
cats quelle logique
il ya d'ailleurs surtout reprend b4 en
plus le point positif c'est que ce
retour cd on pouvait faire tour des huit
échecs pour échanger une tour en force
assez dommage c'est quand même quelques
erreurs c'est un peu embêtant les mecs
même même si vous jouez pas malin est là
il ya tour b2 sa tournée mythe ça fout
ici ça touré chaix a trouvé chez avec ça
et toi quand il ya le pion à trois ça
arrive ça gagne cette histoire là non
mais c'est dans l'âge que c'est des
petites scories quoi est-ce que je joue
ce soir n'en jouerai un jour et demain
l'aréna officielle et j'aurais peut-être
un petit peu l'aréna francophone l'aréna
bitstream pardon à la tour d un joli ça
gagne aussi sa matin au 6 mai autour des
1 ça permettait de gagner de manière
forcée maître yoda qui a perdu alors
argué grave à tort alors qu'est ce que
c'est ça ou la la il ya eu il ya eu un
souci quelque part un cat 6a oui à
fusionner le complètement 5 ok on va
voir la technique légendaire de gramat
tort grâce à fait penser à des gravats
je suis perdu ouais je sais pas est ce
qu'on est nombreux sets à rien dire il
ya beaucoup de joueurs on est 50 et
calque donc ça c'est en et 49 pardon est
presque 50
donc c'est bien pour une arena
francophone c'est cool on est de plus en
plus nombreux à les jouer la cavalière 3
c'est bien joué et ils menacent à tout
il veut faire ou 5
et voilà on est assez nombreux sont les
120 sur le stream 56 40 sur l'arena
franchement c'est bien
franchement c'est bien je suis content
de voir que sur ses strings du jeudi
petit à petit on se bat on a trouvé
notre note notre petit public quoi c'est
agréable et c'est sympa merci à vous
alors au cinq au prochain et ça va être
gagné jetez un oeil au classement
alors là oui c'est malin voire fasciste
pour essayer de brouiller les pistes
mais ça suffit pas au classement ritan
qui est leader mais on est fan
malheureusement comme j'ai dit son petit
classement elo malheureusement va
sûrement coûté
bien souvent coûté allez on va regarder
où ils crachent you we will rock you
nouveau sur sur ce stream drapeau russe
on va voir ce que ça donne contre motus
maudissent qui joue pas mal je crois que
j'ai joué dans un stream pédagogie qui
n'était pas ma pas mauvais comment on
fait pour rejoindre l'aréna en faut
d'abord que tu rejoignes le club je mets
les deux liens le premier l'un puis le
deuxième la fois que le club ait rejoint
faut que tu ailles dessus donc une
petite italienne
si djoko piano peut-être même du copiale
ni si moi je suis pas spécialiste mais
ça ressemble alors il faut manger cinq
qui vient alors est-ce que ça peut être
prématurée parce que quand tu mets le
fou rapidement g5 tu peux te prendras
justice g5 à layton c'est le pôle from
esprit français est complètement après
mazaugues loup le mitroglou de cannes
paul et ain leuh paul-froment à speedy
de des arénas premier à 4,480 alors
attends fouet parce que j'ai j'ai mal
fait le lien assez horrible d'avoir le
petit truc qui s'est mis à ses chiens
désolé d remis deux fois mais en fait
c'est mon les deux fois il faut aussi
c'est maintenant qu'est ce qui va se
passer et avoir un petit des cavaliers
h4 l emballage et croient plutôt pour
les blancs quand même là je crois que
c'est le bon scénario
il ya la dame
le cavalier ici j'ai pas très bien placé
au final la dame en un set qui le bloque
le cavalier qui arrivèrent f5 la dame
qui arrive hergé droite ça va doubler
par ici je sais pas je sens le mauvais
scénario ici pour qu'arras f5 je sens le
scénario difficile pour modus
motus et bouche cousue
[Musique]
ou peut-être mots du us car il ya cinq
pas idiot et c'est un bon coup de
résistance les ventes est fou pranger
six cavaliers f5 assez chiant quand même
un truc c'est qu'une fois que cavalier
vient sur f5 c'est un enfer quoi il va
connecter avec la dame dont le point ce
qu'on va faire et feu n'est pas aisé pas
souligner mais à cause de cavalerie g6
fourchette et une fois que le truc
arrive sur f5 mais alors là c'est d'un
chiant qui va se faire des dommages car
à trop des dames g3 il va te taper là ça
va être hyper difficile à résister quoi
j'avais déjà d'un match 4 ça crée une
première menace qui est qu'il prend un
fils tourcoing f6 et tu peux aussi aura
décidé de faire très froid kg 5 voire
tour f 3 tours h3 et faire péter le le
truc c'est hyper désagréable à ses fins
et plus que désagréable cavaliers à 5
est hors jeu et tous rêvent trois tours
g3 mon avis ça arrive un bon il défend
kg 8 c'est bien joué
il connaît les trucs thématiques ouais
après s'ils résistent ils résistent quoi
mais ok froid ou masqué et g5 et j'ai 6
kg 5e là c'est fini
et ouais mais c'était dur on l'a dit que
c'était dur mais je jolie partie on va
regarder un peu super génial bon je
préfère prendre les parties du début
donc on va attendre un peu que ça a
vraiment vous ils creusent sous comptes
française made moi je dis c'est une
partie qui vaut le coup
ce que l'état n'aimons pas droit non pas
du tout je vois souvent des tannes sur
le stream c'est pour ça mais c'est pas
un padawan gêné padawan mais il est papa
down il est souvent sur l'estrie mais
bon je crois qu'il a subies et tonnes
qui a choisi le côté obscur de la force
et qui est en train de suivre les traces
de dark froid mais ce pic de dark pool
quoi dark pool or est en train de
rejoindre les forces et sur tatouine
quoi sur tataouine sur tataouine avec
paul froment speedy ils sont tous les
deux avec un double sa double sabre
laser ou je fais très attention
salzmann tire une française c'est quand
même très inquiétant
il a cédé au côté obscur de la force
c'est décevant ça ça on fait quoi pour
toi là bas une fois que tu as rejoint le
club pièces comme fr il te suffit de te
suffit d'aller sur sur la droite en fait
atteint les tournois et tournament
ben tu vois pas mais attends je vais
relever un peu le truc tu vas dans les
tournaments et tu fais une progresse
face c'est en anglais en cours et arena
francophones et tu rejoins engine
alors que fo harrier et appris appris le
lille
salut qu à l un mouton projet de vidéo
sur le plus isolé avec vlad écoute ça va
pas sortir très bientôt parce qu'on a du
mal à se se capte avec là donc ça va
sortir mais j'imagine courant de l'année
mais pas pas dans les semaines à suivre
à venir on va donc dire que l'éthane
c'est un genre d'anakin skywalker quoi
j'aurais été très bien
tout allait bien on a pensé que c'était
une très très bonne recrue
nous l'avons formés pour devenir djeddah
et puis bon il y à un moment donné il
arriva il a rejoint les forces vêtus de
noir quoi ou de blanc d'ailleurs si on
parle de comment il s'appelle déjà les
cons qui sont en blanc
les droïdes peut-être c'est pas des
droïdes de basses et les droïdes mais
après c'est les gens qui sont en dessous
1 les stormtroopers sont complètement
débile ou quoi c'est génial ils sont
complètement nu quoi j'ai même pas quoi
ça te sert d'avoir des stormtroopers en
fait un jeu je pense qu'ils servent à
rien fait c'est comme le h de la wife a
dégagé quoi moi je les aurai dégagé
failli faire vraiment à rien dans le
film ils sont vraiment là pour décorer
quoi façon ils sont nuls donc espère mal
joué de la part de française man qui
veut essayer de contrer sur f2 j'ai
l'impression que leur tour prend aussi
soudé 4 et honteux honteux mais la
pression là bas mais peut-être qui
inquiète non un f ou des cas dans
stormrise et peut-être qui va lui faire
à ces champions prend tout prend dame
prend tout reprend 3 prend damev six
échecs 3 bougez dame prend b2 et le
cavalier sens pas assez pas mal là ce
qu'il a fait française man 1 c'est pas
mal du tout là ce qu'il a fait
hu a super bien joué franchement je suis
fier de lui
ok mais ça a minima tapas déjà juste à
minima un fou des cats le retour sur
deux tours f2 est ok sur facetime déjà à
minima ça ça doit être excellent pour
les noirs mais salini maxima tu as
peut-être des trucs comme damache quatre
tours prend aussi sa dame h13 eu deux
dames un math donc d'un match 4 safari
maximaliste mais je vois pas pourquoi ça
irait pas il faut f5 chef ou prendre un
et tu craques le fou au prochain dlc
bien jouer c'est bien joué de la part de
française man franchement c'est une
belle partie ok là
voire pas de maths
une enquête est tout bêtement foucher
trois ans fait en 3g un lavage de match
3e deux tours l2 échec ff5 qu'es tu
prends et je frappe à chaque femme bien
joué car il fait tous les bons française
man franchement il est chaud
quand il est chaud france la semaine
champlain
la chante la bei un jeu française man
qui fait une belle partie très bien joué
de sa part
bravo à lui
ah on va regarder notre ami le
charpentier
comment est-ce que ça va se passer pour
le charpentier à le charpentier qui fait
face à son propre à son propre enfant
quoi ils s'effacent à la au système de
londres il va vous faire re 6
je vous le dis tout de suite un an il
faisait il s'est passé ça d'habitude ces
trois dames b si c'est parce qu'il fait
d'habitude de charpentier non non il
s'est planté le charpentier il vous
différemment d'habitude ils jouent
différemment le charpentier
va falloir prendre le truc en f4 et là
j'aime bien le charpentier puisque
germans ces structures de pions les
joues plus tôt avec les blancs quand il
ya le fou qui est resté bloqué ans et 8
et pas quand il est sorti pas quand il
est sorti
peut-être que prendre en c4 ce n'est pas
idiot honnêtement pour isoler le pion
mais bon on s'en va pour les blancs
aussi un joueur par là que c'est pas ces
packs atteint ce café dispatch le pion
f4 qui soutient comme lecavalier st
qu'il va falloir bosser un pur réussira
à faire quelque chose surtout le
dispatch a réussi à installer depuis ans
et 5
j'aurais jamais aimé les changes espion
ce que maintenant les plans peut voir
l'idée de faire tours fc un bar f3 je
trouve que c'est un coup inutile qu'est
ce que tu veux faire tu veux faire tours
fc 1 tu crées une menace tu me l'as de
bouffe bouffe les blanc et noir te
prennes tu reprends et maintenant tu
veux jouer pour damas cissé est attaqué
c'est 6 et à peut-être qu'à ibb et trois
cavaliers à 5
genre tu réussis à faire d'un matisse
qui avait trois cavaliers à 5t le roi du
pétrole quoi c'est de nouveau dallas et
dallas à fond quoi tu es jr tué de
partout quoi mais peut-être les plus
jeunes connaissent pas dallas
je pense pas que les plus jeunes d'entre
nous connaissent dallas et son univers
impitoyable univers complètement
pitoyable enfin latif voilà c'est la
catastrophe à la pour dispatch dispatch
qui peut se faire dispatcher olalalala
mais le japon c'est pourquoi au ladhof
manie la danse pagny tu dois me prends
des quatre échecs assez ça gagner une
pièce a gagné tout à la la quel dommage
quel dommage une faillite majeure permet
à des gens qui connaissent qui ne
connaît pas dallas dans le truck temps
mais si c'est connu quand même dallas
les make a wave reprend des cartes et
chèques intermédiaire olala ça y est
c'est reparti fallait faire tour d un
ici pour essayer de lutter bavard moitié
fou prend un bon ça reste complètement
gagnant un tour b 4 ça va aller pour
pour le charpentier j'ai entendu qu'ils
auraient regagné h si c'était un peu
mais bon ça doit aller structure 2002
des pions blancs qui est mauvaise
115 1 il est plus ici et qui ne connaît
pas non plus dans la sarthe à quel âge
64 artza du coup vix est censé être le
plus vieux 44 balles et non je pense pas
que tu sois le plus vieux ici je pense
qu'on a des gens qui ont plus de balles
et que toi je pense qu'il ya plus âgé
que toi aux cavaliers français 3 au nom
au nom au nom
on la partie lagaf ada ho là là il n'a
pas vu aie aie aie aie aie aie aie oh la
la la la la gaffe fadasse et la partie
des gaff gaff est c'est plus l'auteur
fait c'est la gaffe est terrifiant
et là le roi de dix pages qui parent
oui car on a pas encore mis ses menaces
à 10 et exécutions et je suis encore en
vie pour quelques jours assez bien joué
de la part des deux charpentiers
ma douche connaît dallas tout le monde
prenait dallas et son univers
impitoyable
ce qu'on a vu le moule le spot move for
equality de quinssaines équilibre j'en
parle dans la vidéo de demain d'ailleurs
pas pour en dire du bien
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce qu'il a fait
les charpentiers il est resté avec les
pions f
honnêtement il s'est compliqué la vie de
charpentier je sais pas comment il s'est
débrouillé
il aurait pu créer un pion pas c'est
gratuit mais bon il peut encore faire le
tour avec son roi les des pions et
revenir après mais il s'est vraiment
casser la tête genre quelque part ici tu
peux jeu se prendre prendre effet
racheté 4 c'était le plus simple mais au
moins tu as un pion passé de chaque côté
tu vas gagner j'ai c'est fini mais je
sais pas ce qu'il a foutu
il a voulu être plus malins bon il a
envahi la ville a fini par une car il
est bon c'est encore gagnant je pense
mais c'est vraiment compliqué la vie
beaucoup de gaffes dans cette partie de
rage du charpentier qui pourrait qui
pourrait à mon avis il faisait moins de
gaffes être très fort allant voir au
regard d'une partie de charpentier est
vraiment bon stratégiquement il manque
un peu de passes et affûté s'est dit
pourquoi pas pour en dire du bien du
truc vous fourrez quality bas ça me fait
penser personnellement sous de mouchoirs
equality c'est vraiment du commandeur
pour moi c'est vraiment du marketing et
de la communication cheap
si tu fais un truc pour la communication
qui sont absolument rien qu'est ce que
ça va changer dans l'égalité entre ce
soit les hommes ou les femmes les blancs
et les noirs ou qu'est ce que tu veux
vous donner l'égalité ce que tu veux que
les noirs vous le premier causés chaque
verset fait des actions concrètes quoi
là c'est vraiment du marketing à l'état
pur sans fond derrière
personnellement je trouve qu'il ya aucun
fond et je serais pas contre si c'était
si c'était un coup marketing avec un
vrai fond derrière c'est à dire avec des
choses qui se
ce qui se passe mais si c'est juste pour
le symbole je vois pas au goal et noir
commencer puis qu'est-ce que ça change
en fait c'est là comme c'est c'est de là
que c'est que de la com en fait c'est ce
qu'on voit tout le temps dans le monde
c'est honteux fait des coups de com
énorme et puis rien ne change on reste
tous dans la même merde mais bon t'as eu
un gros coup de com donc une nouvelle
fois ci c'était que un coup de com c'est
un coup de com avec avec du concret
derrière pourquoi pas s'il ya un an
s'il ya une suite à ça je suis pas
contre mais si c'est un coup de com
juste comme ça pour pour faire un clip
sur youtube d'une minute
et dire que les noirs commencent et bien
on est bien entendu envoyer les gens
vers check 24 qui vient de racheter
c'est quand même tu vois enfin c'est un
sujet sérieux sur laquelle on fait que
sur lequel on fait que de la com
je trouve que c'est dommage
personnellement tout ça pour faire
parler tu vois alors que c'est un vrai
sujet ballack sommes alliés forcément
jojo puisque ça fait ça ça fait parler
de tweets et ça fait des retweets de
partout donc c'est de la com c'est du
marketing en son essence et pour chat 24
ils ont fait un batteur ton aujourd'hui
où ils ont fait que sur chat 24 vous
pouvez commencer aujourd'hui avec les
noirs donc après une nouvelle fois je
répète ce que j'ai dit s'il ya des
actions concrètes qui sont faites
derrière je serais plutôt pour pourquoi
pas mais ici c'est vraiment faire que ça
pour faire pour faire du business et
pour faire de l'argent je trouve que
c'est moyen on verra bien
le truc c'est que
après c'est mon point de vue c'est juste
que bon ouais en gros c'est juste le
délire c'est de commencer avec les noirs
pour lutter contre le racisme
tu sais pas enfin après moi j'ai mes
points de vue sur ces trucs là je crois
qu'il ya des vrais trucs à faire il ya
des vrais sujets il ya des vrais
problèmes quoi et ça pour moi c'est
niveau zéro quoi enfin pour moi c'est le
niveau zéro c'est juste pour se faire re
tweeté pour se faire bien voir pour bien
faire son image et faire zéro truc tu
peux donner de l'argent avec kasparov
ont des jeunes qui aide les les a
développés les échecs en afrique
non mais surtout que bon enfin on va pas
passer la soirée là dessus mais pressé
mon point de vue quoi c'est mon point de
vue mais comme viseo gaulle et noir qui
commençait enfin et alors enfin andrew
c'est un jeu c'est un jeu peut-être
qu'il serait intéressant s'est arrêté de
faire les deux joué les blancs contre
les noirs et mettre des pièces m'appeler
différemment je sais pas
ouais c'est débile comme muse et puis
après ça je pense c'est que du business
les ratchet 24 et voilà quoi c'est un
site concurrent de tchatche.com du coup
mais en plus c'est marrant parce que
dans la dans la vidéo du rire jaune dans
les blagues qui faisait hier il disait
ça qu'aujourd'hui si on faisait les
échecs on dirait que le jeu est raciste
c'est juste
donc
1 tour 8 donc je pense qu'ils doivent
échanger sur la colonne eux le char
quantique fait une bonne partie la plus
tôt les blancs qui sont peut-être
symboliquement mieux parce qu'ils ont le
bon fou
mais est-ce qu aux bons fous ils jouent
vraiment je sais pas j'aime sommes tous
en train de s'échanger que peut-être
fait retour ici dame cet échec fin
peut-être avec les noirs tout juste
échangé en force et à les faire annuler
un je pense pas que les blancs puisse
vraiment joué sur le fou de cases
blanches ici le fou il va à venir ans et
si on sait s'il va couper cette
diagonale je pense que charpentier peut
faire une belle nul ici pour bon moment
ils changent pas et dames mais c'est pas
grave les blondes est obligé de le faire
eux-mêmes c'est bien
main
donc c'est 6
on croyait ces trois récits 6,5 non mais
pour moi les échecs en réalité le truc
de blanc et noir dans ma symbolique à
moi en fait dans ce que je pense c'est
moi j'veux pas si on veut parler de ce
que je vois comme philosophie dans les
échecs je suis passé quelques jours à
quelques à [ __ ]
quelqu'un a quelque chose à [ __ ] mais
pour moi en fait les blancs et les noirs
c'est le bien et le mal et c'est juste
pour montrer que le bien et le mal c'est
surtout une question de perspective
c'est qu'en fait une personne peut
penser qu'elle combat pour le bien une
autre pour le mal mais vu de son côté de
l'échiquier en fait le bien et le mal
c'est quelque chose qui est très
subjectif et du cou et du coup tu es tu
as tu te bats juste pour un camp pas
parce que tu dois en fait t'as pas
vraiment le choix enfin pas forcément
pas toujours le choix et du coup moi
c'est cette vision là c'est que quand tu
as les noirs en fait tu joues pas
vraiment pour le mal en réalité c'est
juste que de ta perspectives à toi ben
c'est le bien et inversement est juste
tu vas tu fais ce que tu veux et tu vois
là moi je le vois comme ça en réalité
mais après c'est ma vision du truc quoi
je vois je vois ça comme ça je reçois un
combat entre le bien et le mal et machin
est symboliquement et que c'est que
c'est que c'est une question de
perspective
ouais un peu comme le signé liant ouais
je vois ça comme ça le mot ce premier
mois joue je pense que c'est là sans fin
c'est la symbolique du truc quoi
celui-ci est bizarre un jeu est un jeu
c'est tout près on voit jardin ce qu'on
veut quoi
ouais ça face à face mais bon après
c'est ma vision du truc c'est pas c'est
pas du tout la vision du c'est comme ça
que je vois les choses en fait
mais après chacun chacun fait comme il
veut tu vois c'est pas un truc que
j'impose a personne tu vois c'est même
pas le cnca même pas été pensé comme ça
c'est moi qui le voit comme ça un point
bas presque grand charpentier legrand
charpentier est-ce que charpentier va
réussir à flag et ce serait quand même
classe donnée la nuit le charpentier
berra l'eau franchement ce serait classe
de faire nul bon ça c'est un truc semi
amical charpentier qui va perdre mais
franchement c'est pas classe classe de
la part de père alors franchement je
suis premier a pas être classe mais là
y'a pas d'enjeu merlot qui est mal
classé charpentier qui est sympa
franchement ça me fait un peu mal au
coeur de voir charpentier perdre comme
ça
ouais ça fait mal au coeur
mais peut-être du foot est roi qui va
marcher pour les blancs ouais il aurait
peut-être pu faire l'effort de faire un
petit fou détroit un truc qui pouvait
mettre charpentier ça me fait mal au
coeur
non ma vraie voilà enfin comme je vous
disais c'est comme ni de couleur tu vois
moi je le voyais plus comme ça tu vois
moi je le vois je voyais plus dans le
délire blanc bien mal noir tu vois alors
et un nom il vous contre un joueur
faible
mais bon je n'ai pas le truc réduit et
une couleur de peau des des pièces les
blancs dans le clan du mal va inciter
côté noir oui du coup les blancs sont
dans le camp du mal
complètement tester ma vision du truc en
fait de mettre en perspective mais
chacun peut voir le truc comme il veut
mais la manière dont je vois pas les
échecs ce qui est sûr c'est de voir que
de penser que c'est un combat entre des
gens de couleur blanche contre des gens
de couleur noir tu as à ça c'était pas
mon délire
c'était pas mon délire paraissent par
espace parce que j'imagine quand je vois
qu'en joie des pièces déchets donc
oui vraiment contre blood berzerker
joueurs japonais peut-être japonais on
sait pas
bon là on
qu'est ce que ça donne cette position le
fou c'est 8 est enfermé pour le moment
3 ça peut-être dame b3 ici pour les
blanches parce c'est intéressant comme
dame b3 la dame me paraît mal placé sur
la colonne c est un coup comme dame b 3
me paraît intéressant pour s'en prendre
aux pions bessette et puis du coup si la
déviance et 7 ce sera une cible et
surtout ses six on a peut-être des 5
vous faisait 5 intermédiaire est
intéressant aux siens mais rapt attire
dame b6 du coup bon damas cinq aussi
d'algérie vient dame b 3 quand même je
suis assez d'accord avec ce coup damas
cinq tamda masingue investisseurs d'amd
troisième miens
mais cette fois c'est ici mais françois
surtout au 16e tour c'est 8 tu as tu
fait fouiller sa gamme a5 thomassin il
faut sept tours c'est 8
j'ai le sentiment que commencer par dan
b3 ça faisait ça mange pas de pain tut
enlever la dame d'une case un peu
mauvaise
tu voyais ce qui se passait comme ça me
paraissait cinq hommes coup en fait
toute façon il y vient à la bouche et la
dame il fait fausse est maintenant way
ainsi peyo a forcé un des cinq des cinq
pays non plus penser peut-être d'amd 6
mai des cinq jeux jouables
vous êtes sûr c'est une dame b 3 rennes
on est peut-être ça allait un
les 3l peut faire peut-être dames c'est
s'agissait pas pour ton truc ça tours
ces huit dames les trois dames c'est
cette bon je sais pas peut-être que ça
marche c'est ya encore des comptines une
continuation mais sans pouvoir faire
cavalier f5 colmater attaqué ray tu sais
pas j'ai l'impression de quelqu'un ne
sont pas très bien débrouillé mais sur
calais 5 avait pas que les fous prend b5
françois jacq
ça représente que blood berzerker qui
s'en sort pas mal intéressant j'ai
quatre peut-être sur foot français il
veut d'ailleurs faire juste tours france
et 1 et se garder le fouet f6 pour faire
d'un meutre wada match 6
c'est très très bien joué ça de la part
de louis brémond d'avoir laissé de ce
sacrifice de qualité bravo à toi très
bien joué cinq fils de qualité pour
affaiblir les cases noires cavaliers qui
est un caillou c'est tu peux même pas
mais kg cette dame ici cavaliers h 8
dames hafsi ses cavaliers et cavaliers
g5 qui arrive est complètement en train
de mystifier les noirs et qui a rédigé 5
qui arrive en force et les blancs qui me
semblent mater en force un teddy retour
france et 3 kg cinq ans même tour france
est un roi j'ai deux tours j'ai un roi
bouge thameur 3g 2 c'est fini je pense
que même sacrifié comme ça après jour a
assuré coin plutôt répondre ces trois
films français troistorrents ces trois
reprises ces trois prises ici et kawaï
et g5
il n'y a pas de père pète dame un roi ni
deux il n'y a pas de dames 4 donc je
pense que ça va mater en force très bien
joué
great bear the rocker qui est pas mal
joué pourtant mais ça va pas suffi
arrive à perdre on va essayer de
regarder une dernière partie qui est
quand même plus ou moins en cours parce
qu'il reste 2 minutes 40 et ça devrait
pas finir normalement ça ça vient de
finir donc c'est mort ce qu'on regarde
le charpentier en fin de partie
on arrive à gagner charpentier j'ai vu
man u man u ça fait un moment qu'on
l'avait pas vu alors on va finir sur
manu manu avec les blancs manu qui est
mal autant et qui peut la perdre encore
il ya peu de temps mais une position
quasi intérêts mêmes positions gagnantes
mais le truc c'est qu'il aura pas assez
de temps pour la finir normalement manu
qui devrait terminer sur une nulle mon
avis elle a vraiment une belle partie
avec le sacrifice de qualité là c'était
vraiment sympa parties précédentes on
est bien tombée et la manu à mon ami je
vois pas dans quel monde y perd mais le
truc c'est camille arrêt subit 42
tournoi et que ya encore trois minutes
20 pour un modus
ça devrait pas suffire à noter demain
l'arena l'aréna real qui sera à 20h
puisqu'on nous on n'a pas changé d'heure
encore alors que les américains ou les
serveurs chez ce point comme son change
et les heures manuka un peu lent faire
vous prend 1,3 tempo aimait jouer pour
le andes qui je vous laisse ces poulets
commentaire salut tout le monde et merci
andes et à demain soir sur la chaîne
bitstream et bien entendu samedi 15h15
15h50 chènevis rim k norvège le gros
match et dans vg ans sur celui de
tournoi ça va finir
dommage hein pour manu qui méritait une
belle victoire là sur cette partie à
l'effet refuge et un tour c1
il aurait mérité de la gagner
honnêtement rsq 30 secondes c'est
impossible
du ski peut juste attendre manu qui
envoie mais est prêt move to the past
fermeté mais je crois qu'il ya pas de
risque il va réussir à faire dame manu
je suis tout à fait pu faire gagner s'il
y avait une menace si j'avais tout
reprend h3 et fourrages de bonbons une
façon ça aurait pas suffi donc c'est
anne qui gagne mais sans vraiment gagner
buber god
fini premier mais qui a déjà un
abonnement diamant puisqu'il est maître
fide à voir est ce que est ce qu'on va
ordonner des mains à quelqu'un d'autre
ou pas je ne sais pas mais bon et
annette à n'y aura pas le tueur a pas de
diamants là dessus trop petit et l'eau
le fils le fils français de deux pôles
français spie psp ds psp b ou usb comme
vous voulez saint-pétersbourg
sur ce les mecs vous dans un gros merci
d'avoir suivi si vous l'avez pas encore
fait je vous invite à aller voir la
vidéo du rire jaune sur les échecs a
sûrement quelqu'un qui va mettre un
petit lien dans le chatt merci à vous et
on se retrouve demain soir à 20h pour
l'aréna et donc comme je disais samedi
15h50 pour le choc en huitièmes de
finales de pro che slick le remets un
grand merci à tous et à bientôt
ciao ciao